hey guys this is andrew for
trainsensors.com i'm a professional
trader and i've been working for several
big investment banks like hsbc or
commerce bank
and i'm right now doing some youtube
videos because i want to show you guys
everything
i learned at work as a professional
trader and i want to pass the knowledge
so today i want to make a quick update
on the bitcoin because some crazy stuff
is happening
like the past weeks and especially
yesterday so i want to explain to you
guys
what is my view on this cryptocurrency
let's get into it
[Music]
so very quickly let's start with the
news so yesterday we had
elon musk saying tesla purchases 1.5
billion
dollars in bitcoin all right so the
market capitalization of bitcoin is
around 700
now maybe 800 billion us dollar so it's
like
around 1.2 of the total market cap so
it's a lot
the reason behind so tesla the company
had more than 19 billion us dollar in
cash
uh all right so they need to put this
money somewhere and as you guys know
as i said already before in other videos
i did on
bitcoin a lot of hedge fund managers are
just like companies are buying actually
bitcoin to protect uh themselves against
inflation the inflation of the us dollar
that might happen because of the heavy
uh printing that we see uh since the
copy crisis has started
so this 20 billion u.s dollar are
actually at risk
so putting them into bitcoin is actually
kind of a hedge against this
very high inflation scenario that might
happen one day
all this has actually started guys two
weeks ago
so two weeks ago uh ellen musk just put
a hashtag
bitcoin on his twitter bill and these
guys gave us this
first move up that we had here all right
some
on the four hours time frame and here
guys this was two weeks ago we had a 20
move up right now what do we have same
thing guys
25 percent move up and this is again
due to elon musk making some
announcement about
his investment in this cryptocurrency
so of course he might have some issues
he was already
fined 20 million us dollar for tesla and
for himself so 40 in total
by the sec because he was actually doing
some tweets about
tesla back in 2018 and he's keep doing
this guys he's buying some bitcoin and
then he's posting on the social medias
that he
thinks i do at this point think bitcoin
is a good thing
and i'm a supporter of bitcoin you know
after having bought
a lot of uh them it looks like a bit
some um
you know front running we can call it
like this you know it's it means like
you make your move
before actually people do it it's like
market manipulation you can you know
say a lot of bad words on this but elon
musk
doesn't care because he's the richest
man on earth and
he is full of cash now let's do a bit of
technical analysis
so once again for those who follow me on
instagram
i try to give you here a lot of
information
i was seeing this descending triangle
which is usually a continuation pattern
so i was bullish
like for the past three weeks i was
expecting here we have some convergence
and then a breakout on the upside which
actually happened
now we are here so the breakout has been
confirmed already last week i did a
video on this i was telling you guys
maybe you have
one more chance to buy it at 33.34
i think it didn't come back it was maybe
around here
and i was very convinced we're going
higher and i didn't know of course about
the news
i'm just talking about the technicals
but why here it has gone that high
guys because many people are maybe aware
of what is happening and you know
technical
analysis is just giving you the
information that you don't have
you know because it's in the flows all
right so you read the flows you have the
information
whatever the information is you can use
it and make your trades
here it was a very nice level to buy
so now uh where are we heading we're
going to 55 000 guys i'm gonna show you
very quickly how i got this level
and if you want to buy i have some
friends that asked me yesterday
uh for example a friend that is like uh
in london
asked me he has a lot of different
investment and he asked me where should
i buy
the stuff i told him careful you know
it's not a nice level to buy 45 000 but
you might buy 33 now i check more
carefully
and on the short term actually the first
support is actually
eight thousand thirty seven thirty eight
thousand all right
so here you can buy some if you're
really uh bullish
and about target so very quickly
let me show you how i found for those
who interested
i've done this already but i'm going to
do it again for those who haven't
watched my previous videos
so basically i do a bit of uh iliad
and so you get wave theory and a bit of
fibonacci extension prediction as well
so here for example what i see is that
we are doing the fifth wave so let me
show you very quickly on the
you know if i if i show you the whole
chart guys on a weekly basis
so we have you know it's a one two three
four five so it started here at two
one two three four five all right so we
are doing the fifth wave of this
entire move that started ten years ago
each
wave can be split into five waves each
like your motif wave can be split into
five waves so here one two three four
five
then abc zigzag one two three four five
and in each third wave i can find uh
five waves again
one two three four five one two three
four five this is the past
but now the same thing is going to
happen guys so we are doing exactly the
same thing as we did before
here we had a zigzag here we have a flat
because in idiot wave theory
if the second wave is zigzag usually the
fourth one is a flat
for those who want to know more about
idiot wave theory and all the different
uh characteristics of each pattern how
to use them and how to help you read a
chart using it
you can click on the link in my in this
description of this video
and you're going to receive a free video
that i almost finished about
idiot wave principle so here zigzag here
flats and now we're going higher and the
question is
how big is going to be this fifth wave
so how big
it's hard to predict maybe my maximum
level would be around 350 000
but in like you know maybe two or 23
something like this but for now
we are just you know replicating this
wave and going
from one resistance to the next one so i
use fib retracement fib extensions to
get it so i measure this wave i apply
this extension to the bottom of my fifth
wave
which is also also the bottom of my
force wave and i just see the different
ratios
so the most likely one is one point six
one eight so thirty five thousand
we were there we had some consolidation
and the next one is two point six one
eight guesses fifty five thousand
so what is likely to happen is that we
have the same
thing some consolidation around this
level so it doesn't mean
it's going to be the maximum level maybe
it's going to go to 60 000 and then come
back but it's going to
make a post the market is going to make
a pose at this level
and you're going to have at least two or
three weeks i think to you know sell
your position maybe buy again if you
think it's going higher
and then we're gonna check again and
reconsider the whole analysis but for
now we are going to 55 000. there is
nothing that can stop the bitcoin going
there
in my view all right guys so that's it
for me i hope you enjoyed this video if
you did please don't forget to click the
like
sub and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and i'm gonna do many more on
bitcoin and the other cryptocurrencies
guys so stay close to show